I wonder just as a Christian right when
I joke and say this stuff I
it's like am I being disobedient to God
because as a boss right I'll talk to
um
and uh an employee and I'll be like why
didn't you just listen because I've got
the bigger plan right so it's like me
talking to God were there things that I
did in this interview that were
disobedient to God and and for those
things I I pray and I repent for
anything that I've said that was
disobedient to God but humor is not one
of them joking I feel like humor is the
way we avoid so much suffering in the
world it's the way to it's like a
catalyst for love like it's a way to
people that gone through some of the
darkest trauma that I've ever met
through War I just came back from
Ukraine
They're laughing
they're they're making jokes that's the
best way to deal with dark times I don't
know what it is about like humans I feel
like humor
that's the best way to social engineer a
good future I think is humor not taking
[ __ ] too seriously that's the problem
with censorship one of the things I
really suffer
is humor jokes maybe going too far on
the jokes you mentioned Anthony Jeselnik
that guy goes hard
that guy goes really hard and it's great
he crosses all he crosses all the lines
and he's that's why he's a genius and
that's what people feel is refreshing
when he does it
I don't know what it is but then it's
like hurtful when I do it but I tell you
something that was interesting I'm
pretty sure
Anthony doesn't like sorry for his
assumption but just most comedians I
know didn't vote for Trump
that's interesting not saying there
aren't comedians that did but just the
ones I know because I live in California
right but they have an appreciation for
Trump because of the sense of humor yeah